ah there you are wondering what's going  on eh  one question first are you feeling  anything that can be construed as  explosive cell death no wonderful let's  get started  [Music]  welcome to the edge of the galaxy the  frontier of space well at least it was  until the corporation's bought it  branded it and started selling it at  ludicrously inflated prices and the rest  of your fellow settlers abandoned on the  edge of the colony I'd save them myself  but the Boers got a bounty on my head so  that's why I thought you out you appear  capable  look I get it taking on the corporation  is left us with two choices bad and  worse but you have to choose and you  have to choose now you know you didn't  have to shoot either one right but it's  fine I guess you just keep being you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Spicer's choices not responsible for any  feeling of vertigo wonder or hundred you  may've experienced while watching this  advertisement  [Applause]